et
[Musique]
un hacker attaquent nos marchés
financiers quatre grandes banques
c'est tout ce qu'on sait si on veut des
indices sur l'identité du hacker il nous
faut un homme qui s'appelle hathaway
qu'est ce qu'on souhaite ce type là
c'est un hacker condamné à 15 ans de
prison
diplômé du amati un programmeur de génie
vous allez commué la peine en échange de
l'identification et de l'arrestation du
mec que vous traquez veau ciré
conditions revendications politiques
attaque terroriste
il a fait une déclaration ce mec va tout
faire sauter il n'y réfléchis par deux
fois
se déplacer de maux chicago et
maintenant la chine ce n'est que le
début
signaux codés dans quel but
[Musique]
le gros coup et à venir si vous êtes
découvert
vous êtes un homme mort faux furent
il ne s'agit pas d'argent il ne s'agit
pas de politique
je peux m'en prendre à n'importe qui
à n'importe quoi
n'importe où